so team Teen Wolf we've got Holland here
and Max we've got some questions for you
today right first up what would Aidan
and Lydia have said to each other if
they could had a final scene together
what do you think with the burning
things they would wanted to say to each
other I know I'm gonna give this to you
because last time you answer this it was
marvelous I'm gonna say it again I told
him I'm trying to remember that he
should be a better dresser was that it
is that it I don't remember no but
that's even kinder thank you we know
what was it what was it I forget I know
I had to answer this question last week
on my deathbed that's so cute
we don't know Lydia Lydia better dresser
no what was that forget
I honestly forget what was the one that
I said I also said be close you said you
should wear more skinny jeans I think oh
yeah that's yeah I'm still more detail
oriented last time it has such depth and
heart I don't know why anyone in the
world likes her but whatever I also said
that he's not he's not as bad if a guy
as he thought he was was my real answer
okay I like that um what did you think
that what would you reply of being
something epic something in Latin this
is till death yeah my beauty no that's
just how he talks a French cry so that
wouldn't be for a very writer or like
give myself an epic like good night
sweet prince to myself that'd be pretty
sweet did you communicate wish why do
you speak to French girls didn't know
talked about that yeah no I mean I
probably how a degree I'm a little bit
more liberated when I'm in France I just
kind of see whatever I want Vinny I
don't I don't really know what I'm
saying so I'll say stuff like kisses
until our deaths together like oh I've
met a goddess now I can die happy again
I don't know really what I'm saying but
they seem to like it so I like it too
beautiful English I love it I can see
you shaking your head though without
what are you doing is your son Enoch so
that list is how he talks to Crystal and
I every single day when we always to
work together well now I kind of do
actually mm-hmm why I called you like
when he first started shooting Holland
it's always super awkward so I always
call her I've got I'll look it's my wife
and she hi wifey yeah where I was like
he's a very odd way of working with his
love address yeah and talking of love
interest who we do ship on the shiok
with so much shipping talk online yeah
the best STD ever oh I got pity I sound
like an STD at 88 even subversive so
romantic
oh my yeah I've you should have said
that on my deathbed that be hey yeah
what an STD always have 88 again um I
think a Tia was a song wasn't it I just
like Sarah McLachlan was it really
mmm-hmm that may be one of those like
Tony Danza tiny dancers situation
whatever I'll take it um was the
question
but what was her uShip uh who does she I
said I would um ship uh what was it
called card cook origin cogent cogent
coaching Kate argent our coach and uh
junior yeah definitely that's it we're
coaching styles would that be what would
that be
Stosh who likes ditch yeah I was like
Coco while Kyle's quails stomach I think
starch is better stow your coaching
Jared isn't there like a guy who's I was
yelling at Jared for throwing up those
stairs Greenberg Greenberg Greenberg and
coach
yeah Greenberg and coach that'd be a
wonderful relationship a lot of
projectile vomit reach reach reach I'm
loving life from living it now who has
got the best amps on the show I mean I
mean ya know Holland Roden I have no abs
there's God no I don't like I don't
particularly I'm not some I'm not a fan
of the six-pack on on maybe I'll put
also just me um but I would do Declan
hoechlin yeah are you kidding me yeah
yeah you could really although junior
and Ian like junior Jairus rich credit
for his young Fountain of Youth age you
could you could chop a salad on them
like they're okay
um we do our laundry yeah a washboard
that's what it's for
got it I just settle a drop today
dropping salad that works good - yeah
what power or ability would you like to
have in the show you have any power or
ability I think we should have like you
didn't like your fisting why I was
trying to avoid saying that like super
fist okay that's pretty cool a little
like Dragon Ball Z stuff right there um
I don't know invisibility would have
been cool right like a one ring I hope
maybe next season I'll happen some sort
of epic ring I've always liked the Alex
Matt complex I don't know if you have
this in the UK The Secret Life Alex Mack
that was about 15 to 20 years ago okay
and yeah it's where there's a chemical
act parents were scientists and so there
was a chemical accident I don't know
what she was doing at the lab at the
time but she could morph into this wall
yeah aqueous puddle well.all puddles
reckless but substance and go yeah go
into doors and hear things it was kind
of like she was invisible but she's a
puddle yeah hahahaha but she's a baby oh
you'd like to be a puddle you'd like to
be a populace I think I fell I he's got
the coolest ability on the show at the
moment who has a core stability less
than it gets any aspect of things yeah
it's it
yeah the kidney gets named is pretty big
hole like go thing and the white room
being his brain that was cool
yeah going that it's like the inception
take on things kinda sorta then the kids
name was great and so was the kid soon a
with the ninetails even nothing was kind
of pathetic they didn't really work too
well they didn't ya I was cool I'm just
definitely cool powers and the
berserkers on this episode you see me
yeah how would you know what those are
creatures as I saw them I didn't work
with them and I know about berserkers
cuz I like mythology and I'm worried now
it mentioned the super werewolf if you
could merge with anybody else on the
show like the super werewolf we're going
to avoid this for better
this here would it be is this washer
what would the result be this question
might come back to haunt me
I would merge with myself I will make a
horrible answer because anyone else is
just gonna come back to bite me oh thank
god
art imitates life and life imitates art
you did that with your brother already
it's like merging with yourself kind of
sort of like a twin the fats you can't
see me as an individual person just
breaks my heart
they're the same person they share
kidneys would you merge way I would
probably merge with I don't know I
always say coach for all my answers um I
probably merge with coach even though I
I'd have to I'd have to have a mute
button on him because the jokes don't
stop and so I would merge with like a
therapist and coach I'd merged with the
counselor and coach so there'd be like a
nice balance of when he's you know a
little too um needy in the joke category
she could coax him down and so it'll be
a nice balance to live with I kind of
would emerge with Deaton - he knows
Japanese yeah Japanese like a knowledge
of fine powders from mystical trees like
it would be great
that was mountain ash by the way Oh
conquer Narnia together yeah I love it I
can see it happening right now if you
could bring any of the creatures into
the show what would you like to bring
into Teen Wolf I just want to cuddle a
little puppy I like the one that was
hiding out of the dumpster in one one
episode yeah it was a cute dog I'm gonna
bring that back that one little dog that
died that was a cute dog right there
should have been probably my dog acting
in that scene but I'm I'm gonna go ahead
with that dog what are some cool
creatures I mean want to wear Welsh over
at a loss for words
I suppose Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
for Christmas oh I prefer going in
uh-huh yeah if we're going in that
category I'm gonna throw it back to em J
Fox 80s style and go with the gremlins
for sure gremlins would be really fun we
get a furbies as the like stand-in
gremlin
yeah that'd be wake and cool or they
wake up in your freaking closet at 3
o'clock I'm Riley man it's like I turned
you off dude ever happen to you I never
had a Furby now yeah they were raised in
the 1950s um amazingly so yeah so I'm
gonna go through Dolph maybe yeah I love
it both fantastic answers now if you
could pick a favorite prop from the show
what is your favorite prop I gotta put
me with the Molotov cocktail that's a
cool bra yeah
did I necessarily have to work with the
prop or any problem I mean I wanted to
shoot the crossbow art and swords are
pretty cool too yeah I played with the
swords though cross bows crossbows bows
and arrows yeah
Christopher archery lessons and that's
done no way cool
how much pranking gaze on on sand who is
the biggest troublemaker I said that set
now is quite traditional and
professional so we don't really have any
pranks but back in the day I would say
Barbara Vasquez our costume designer
she's a pretty big pregnant yeah I can
say back in the day I found a funnel
cake this was not on set and I pretended
that I bought it but I found it upside
down on a bench and I gave it to my
brother and I watched him eat the whole
thing and then told him I found her
upside down on a bench well first he
threw up and then he really chased me
around row yeah so that wasn't on set
but that was a precursor to the
leftovers yeah it's giving me somebody
very quick like that idea
um what is the most outlandish rumor
that you either heard about the show or
yourselves well the Mary Jane spider-man
thing was pretty insane for me I was
like I felt almost embarrassed because
of course you'd like to be a part of a
project like that but it's embarrass
when you're like no it's it's not true
um yeah my brother kind of proliferated
a rumor that I had a third nipple and I
just like it
I just like to clarify that yeah I might
have a third nipple uh maybe I don't
have a third nipple
but be a spokesperson for people with
their nipples well quite frankly it's no
one's business how many nipples I have
but as far as I know I don't have one so
you know gonna be Nibin spokesman any
time yeah I just wanted to clarify that
thank you thank you I try oh how about
if you could use one word to describe
the following characters in the show
what would it be
Stiles um well uh t-shirts t-shirts he
does wear clever t-shirts teachers Derek
um so cuddly soft little Twinkie Center
yeah
sculpt earnest yeah I mean it's kind of
Scott's character I'm so glad you're
coming with me all these nifty bantering
before I can now I'm holding in my cute
Ethan you know you take anything um
there is a key no no yes no no we we
always gave Ethan flack a little bit
because give you flak you gave him flat
Ethan was kind of a wuss like I don't
want to fight so yeah so uh we would say
um should we just go with her nest again
so our - so earnest except for the
following earnest Aidan earnest
no no earnest um what'd you decide oh so
handsome
uh one word is it that's it dawn I'll
take it
Lydia screamer that's an answer he's
used before huh Tara's answer that's
she's a banshee that's for real I know
that's true
Kira and Amalia oh they get uh for both
um can we combine it
faux lesbian no yeah they had the I
there was like this random scene that
made a lot of sense
he said that them together curium Elia
yeah I'm gonna say bad ass [ __ ] but
bad ass [ __ ] will go with that too
they have a lesbian
they don't though that's the problem
there was like it was faux it was like
not real huh I didn't know that and
finally I did ask Max's before but if
you could bring any actor into Teen Wolf
who would you like to bring in um well
we always Joe the Andrew Garfield said
he would want to be a part of team or
for an episode but I'm gonna do a
cop-out I'm gonna go with Basketball
Diaries leo
and say Dane DeHaan it's been great
talking to you thank you so much for
taking the team team wolf challenge
thank you for having us thank you
you